[Music]
four years ago I was basically
unemployed I Wanderer with no home
but now I'm a husband
and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
and I did pass
my job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion people
every known species
to this coldest place home
that doesn't mean they don't like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds there
I'm gonna murder his family
and burn his kingdom Kingdom to ask
you must be stopped for a global
meltdown is imminent
someone might be able to help us who
you look rough
good job little brother high five do not
call me brother
I cannot believe you let this happen
yeah well I hate this job true king
builds Bridges right
King builds Bridges
we need to find Manta he's different now
he's stronger than before
it's the black Trident
so in King outland's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
upon them all
we're trying to start magic is spreading
he means to end the one life
[Music]
yeah
I don't know what lies ahead but we
can't leave our children in a world
without hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
[Music]
if you lead the Seven Kingdoms will
follow
[Music]
thank you